Speaker 1: So we discussed Dan Crenshaw getting
harassed, Ted Cruz getting confronted by far right
wingers at this event in Texas, the GOP convention
in Texas that occurred over the weekend. While at
the same convention, these Texas Republicans
voted to officially declare the 2020 election
of Joe Biden illegitimate meeting at their first
in-person convention since 2018. Texas Republicans
on Saturday acted on a raft of resolutions and
proposed platform changes to move the party even
further to the right. They approved measures
declaring the president that President Joe
Biden was not legitimately elected and rebuking
Senator John Cornyn for taking part in bipartisan
gun talks. They also voted on a platform that
declares homosexuality an abnormal lifestyle
choice and calls for Texas schoolchildren
to learn about the humanity of the preborn
child. So the second largest Republican Party
in the country, second only to the national
Republican Party, is coming out and saying that
the election was stolen. They're claiming it.
The election in 2020 was stolen. And this is
incredibly damaging. And frightening. And this
is why, before I say this, though, I have some
conservatives in my audience who say that they
watch my show. They don't agree with me on pretty
much anything, but they feel like I'm level headed
so they can stand to watch it. They get a sense
of what the left believes, but then I've had a
couple of them reach out and say, Except you're
hyperbolic. On the Trump January six, you know,
election being overturned stuff. And so whenever
I hear criticisms, I always want to see if I can
soak it in and see if there's any truth to it
and see if I should change my own behaviors.
But no, this is a great example. This is as bad
as I'm describing it. Our democracy is being
actively undermined by a major political figure
and a major political party. If they get in
power and something like this happens again,
we know that our democracy may not survive
because all the things that Trump tried to do
leading up to January six and even beyond and is
still spouting off about now if he was able to
do successfully. We would not have a democracy
because a individual, an individual who did not
win an election would have stayed in power. And
that is not how a democracy functions. And so, no,
I'm not being hyperbolic on this. I promise you,
even if you're conservative, really? Look at
the fact of the situation. We have a massive
threat to our democracy and it comes in the
form of Trump and the movement, the elite.
And it's shameful that they don't all see.
That there's this active effort to chip away
aggressively at the stability and strength
of our democracy. It's wild, and maybe they
do see it. This would be worse and they just
don't care. They might see it and not care.